[Music]
all right hey everybody happy monday to
you cyber monday that is welcome back it
is 6 43 right now
i'm monica jackson and it's time now for
mondays with monica this week
we are talking about how to decorate for
the holidays without breaking the bank
we know everybody broke as a joke so
we're gonna try to help you out
this is like the decorator event planner
extraordinaire i'm not even kidding i
love this lady tori cooper
is joining us live with some tips from
her own home
and when i tell you this ladies like the
million dollar decorator ladies and
gentlemen she has actually done
million-dollar what million-dollar
weddings million-dollar events
but she knows how to break it down for
us regular folks so tori good morning
thank you so much for being here how you
doing
good morning monica how are you hi and
the same to you
okay i want to get right into it because
i want everybody to have a chance to go
shopping especially since today is cyber
monday
so give us the basic rules of holiday
decorating
it's all about having fun it's getting
the kiddos involved and family
the family involved um bringing in
traditions
uh which is super fun and exciting and
to me since we live in las vegas it's
all about a little bit of that glitz and
glitter
yeah so if i could take you in a little
walk right here okay um
we have we have some candles here and
some beautiful frames
with a mirror and um this simple little
merry christmas
yeah hanging glistening
uh to welcome everyone into your home
and tell your daughter lauren she's
doing a great job on camera one of our
christmas cheese with all kinds of
beautiful bulbs
when you do when you do your christmas
tree you can have any kind of theme from
a man cave tree
to a beautiful candy tree to memory tree
with all the kids photos
this is a monochromatic tree in
silver and gold and white and it's a
flat tree so you can have green trees
white trees
you can have pink trees blue trees
silver trees any color tree you want
these days
okay also in the packaging
with wrapping i like to tie it all in
together but um
probably most likely that most people
don't do that and they just have fun
wrapping
but wrapping is um is also an art itself
and speaking of wrapping in this little
fun bag right
here it's just made your days be murky
and bright um
wow what do we have for the kids we have
some fun little fun little activities of
puzzles and frozen yeah um
all inexpensive little items that could
be in a bag
or we could put it in a stocking for
them that's cute okay
and then they have i mean all kinds of
things this is like rudolph you put it
on your lips
um candy canes and
chocolates we put together a fun little
activity for them
as well for their schooling because at
school they're all doing school at home
with pencils and erasers
and play-doh that's cute um stickers
coloring book
and socks
movies during this during the cold
winter months here
yeah uh we'll watch elf and santa claus
is coming to town
here we set up um uh a selfie station
where the kids can use their um photos
and do an instagram
oh nice photos yeah
put on from wacky
glasses oh perfect for social
yeah so they can do a shout out to their
friends saying we're having fun at home
during coping
um this was a cute little um garden with
the jingle bells on it so we see in the
classes coming to town
nice you can do a what do you call it
one of the reels on instagram with the
jingle bells yes
um here we have a this is an actual real
wreath
and star nursery our friends over there
they have um complimentary green so when
they cut the greens down to the trees
you can just grab
all of the um pieces the little
secondary pieces they also cut off the
wood bark
so i use them for coasters or for candle
holders they'll drill a hole in it for
you
and that's complementary as well um so a
real wreath is a fun accent either on
your door
or as a garland piece on your table
um this this piece right here this
tree all these items everything on here
we'll share that in just a minute okay
but that's the surprise that we're
talking about and
um this was fun for for us to put
together really quick
our own little snow globe ornament very
cute tori i have less than a minute here
i want to ask you a couple questions
before we close out now
looking at all this stuff like i said i
want our viewers to know that it is
affordable
even though you're like this superstar
event planner and decorator
i'm looking at this and i know if i were
at home i'd go yeah right we can't
afford to do this right now it's too
much
i want you to first tell everybody where
you shopped and how much you paid for
everything you just showed us and you
can be very honest about it because we
talked about this and i want everybody
to know
they can do it too so everything is a
dollar
yes everything is a dollar so even here
we have our um
uh coffee uh hot cocoa station
with our little s'more kits that we made
for everyone to do in our backyard with
a fire pit yeah or if you don't have a
fire pit you can warm them up in the
microwave
so just eating here hey tori just to be
clear
you guys have this beautiful um uh
gingerbread
house as well and all the garlands for
that
but it's just it's so you just go
have fun and it's like a scavenger hunt
inside the store see yeah and it's
literally pennies look at this
napkins can you hear me cookies
she gets into it folks she forgets that
we're on live tv
are you there tori can you
tori you say it like it's every day that
everybody can go out and do this kind of
stuff but that's why i wanted to have
you on the show because i know
you can take uh a dollar or 15 cents and
make it look like a dollar so give us
the total
of what you spent for everything you
just showed us
so with everything that we spent in here
of the
little items on this entire tree and the
stocking
and the greeneries and the candies
everything one hundred dollars love it
yes that's what i told you this woman is
something else
that's why sherry says oh my
god yes tori if somebody wants to get in
touch with you how do they go about
doing that because i know a lot of
other events are coming up and we got to
kind of pivot with covet but you know
how to do it so how do we get in touch
with you
i guess people have been having uh
simple gatherings
but making them really festive it's
toriel cooper
on instagram and torielcooper.com
and also on facebook very good i love
you my friends thank you so much that
was great
folks i told you i'm 100 bucks 100 bucks
i knew she was going to do it
all right so i appreciate that and of
course you can catch
mondays with monica at six am right here
on channel eight